[Music]
hello
and welcome to insane endgame
uh i'm reading the chat right now and
i probably should be mentioning this
more often
so one thing that seems to be confusing
some people
is my title never thought i would have
to clarify this
but i am a woman grandmaster i actually
got
all of women titles starting from wcm
which i
really didn't like because of well use
your imagination
um so wcm wfmw imw
and then i got the im which is like
higher than wgm because it's the men
title
kind of so i probably i didn't feel the
need to
speak about this but i saw a comment and
i just wanted to
help put their mind at ease i am also a
feta trainer
still the youngest yeah that's pretty
cool i got it like four years ago
i also saw i wish i was gm dorsa but
you're missing a little w before that
but soon hopefully it will be dr dorsa
but um so i would like to also mention
uh some of the other viewers who wrote
in the chat
so i've actually never been to kurdistan
i wish i was
i went to india a bunch of times and
my favorite thing to eat was you guys
have amazing cute cats
the kids cats in us are just not like
that i just like
so if anybody came from india something
it gets
um from gasoline of course i've been to
gazwin it's uh
jasmine is just very close to tehran
i oh my god you had this them like
flower
cookies flowers chittanis oh i missed
that
and like there was this one restaurant i
absolutely love but it's been like so
many years
probably not there anymore they had like
this amazing tactics
oh my god okay i need to stop drooling
over here
i don't remember what i liked eating in
australia
ah thank you george for your donation
and actually never mind i've never been
to australia oh my god
oh i was supposed to go and i ended up
not making it for the tournaments
visa problems mexico mexico is in my
uh two visit list and there was one
brazil i was in brazil in 2011
i absolutely loved it i have one of one
of my great friends is brazilian
um karen who it also goes to
slu she's amazing so she's so nice
if i need like a dose of niceness she's
usually the person that i contact
um all right so i'm out
of russia okay now all the food is
coming back to me and this is gonna be
like a lesson i'm thinking
sitting here talking about end games of
foods
so um i'm gonna uh
limit myself to just a few food
choices that i gave up and drink some of
this
bitter coffee to help
okay so with that being said hopefully
you guys had a great
food introduction so let's go ahead and
take a look at some end games so
recently i've been doing some end games
that included some like tactical ideas
um more like dynamic versions
and uh some like
just like we've we've been doing a lot
of uh pawn
and king warfare because i've started
i've been teaching that class um
more recently uh on twitch on friday so
we're just basically looking at pawn end
games
we've been doing that for months and i
still haven't run out of material so
we're gonna keep doing it um however
thinking about a little bit more
complex and games i always think about
rook end games and
they are a handful so
let's please uh start looking
at this position um
so full disclosure i have
no idea how i got these files
so i remember when i was in iran when i
was still
like studying and doing chess in iran
back in like 2014-15
one of my uh friends
gave me this like 26 000
endings and studies and i tried my best
to finish them
i think i only managed to do up until
like
five six thousand and i was after that i
was like okay the next 20
well next next next lifetime not not for
me
it was just way too much end game and um
i never actually finished so full
disclosure slash
guilty so
um why to move how do you want to win
yep rook g1 i see one rook g1 i think
actually one is interesting
but i think the thing to keep in mind is
that even with rook g1 you have to
actually know what you're doing
so can somebody tell me what they're
trying to do like
rook g1 king h7 then what if this should
be winning for white right
ah rick d1 awesome
uh yeah don't directly one man
yeah we want to build a bridge exactly
and offset i know you guys got this we
want to build a bridge
we want to build the snowman uh hold on
those are two different things
um so rook g1 king h7 now
does anybody want to tell me what to do
here as
white
keep in mind if king of seven just rook
f2
and he's just gonna keep checking you
and keep going after the pawn and keep
checking you and we'll get back to this
position
these are a very interesting end games
and they're very theoretical
so if you're actually sitting there if
looking at it for the first time over
the board
it's highly likely highly likely you
will not find the right
move so it's better to know what you're
doing beforehand then just sit there and
like
just like be like oh my god what am i
supposed to do
like how am i going to win this so yes
you guys know this rook g4
i wanted to mention that another way to
win this is actually drew k1
rk1 is also possible because
rk1 now you if black plays something
like king g7
you're gonna go to a8 you're gonna come
to d8
and now you're gonna get the king out
and the thing is even if you check check
checks to you you're still gonna just
follow follow follow follow follow
follow
and you get the idea right and if he
tries to
get uh funny with me i'm just gonna
queen it not gonna
i'm not gonna really bother so that's
another way to win
so yeah that's one way rook g4 is
another way
um g4 i think is the easiest way you
just get the king out and the whole
thing is that you want
to get this position and get your
rook to e4 to the bridge that was
mentioned earlier to stop the checks
right
all right great you guys notice
whoa that is not the button i wanted to
push
okay probably this should work
oh my god it's going to take forever
remind me not to save again
what about this game why to move
and not too complex but i feel like
these are some of the very basic things
that if you don't
know you're going to get in trouble
so
insane in the membrane huh that was good
um
yeah queen b6 is the best one whoa why
isn't this all right queen b6 is the
best one queen a5
queen b4 and king c2 voila
alright so you guys know this
black to move
are we gonna queen faster
and also which one to push
it is black to move so we are going to
queen faster
but he's also going to queen with check
so is that something we want to do
or does anybody see anything better
yep it is black to move
ah good to know george i mean good to
know that you know what
where you should work on
so with pawn and games it's very
important to understand
um the queen end game of it as well
because if you make a queen he makes a
queen
then depending on how close the kings
are and what is going
on might not be the best choice
so if like some if you see that for
example this like uh
this doesn't work this um h5 doesn't
work you might want to do something else
but
the problem is in this position you
can't really do anything else your king
is way too far ahead and if you do
something like king g3
your king is not going to be in the
square right
so we can't really do anything else
except for h5
so h5 let's push push push check now
is this winning for white or can black
save this i agree if the queens are
traded then
everything is just easy pc draw
but what about the queens are not traded
what if black what if white gives check
for example
so do we agree that
right now it's up to white to want to
win or to agree to a draw
it is winning right exactly queen g7
you're going to get your queen as close
as possible and then king f2
all right great yeah um what should not
take the draw no and that is why i
showed this position to show you that
even when with like the queen ant games
it really matters um peace's activity
kings how close the kings are
okay um
we don't really need to um check the
billion times
but as white white's gonna win this so
careful h5 is
actually h5
is the only move you can't you don't
really have anything else
but we can't necessarily um
if we don't do h5 we're going to lose
anyway so we might as well try our best
that's the mentality and the idea is
that activity that you shouldn't
that's like if you had the chance to
play that king g2 you shouldn't have
played this game g2
alright i'm not gonna say this
all right so now this is a long
long long
love story between the night and the
rook
so how are we going to win this from
four
whites in the game black played knight
a5 so
white to move how to win this is gonna
be a long and painful one so i would
advise you to embrace it get coffee
popcorn whatever works for you
request 7 right now is not the move to
be played
because you don't want to drop your king
so you got to do something with your
king you got king b5 or king c7
actually king b5 is the best one
knight goes if knight goes to b3
what do you think we should do knight b3
is not the most accurate move
exactly rook d8 awesome we got to cut
we've got to cut the king cut the
knights we're gonna cut everything in
end games
so king b5 knight b7 only move
now how can we continue to cut
careful rook h7 is not a good move king
goes to b8
knight d88 now that is a draw
so rikers eight case seven is not the
best move
i can't understand rick h6 but see we
don't we want to keep
so we want to keep the rook here so we
want to keep the rook in this rank so
the king is cut right and we want to
keep the rook in this ring so the knight
is cut
so the only so we want to so whatever
move we want to do now
we want to force black to do 96 the next
move
so that being said don't you shouldn't
touch the rook from eighth rank so you
gotta do something in the eighth ah
her c8 knight d6 ah that's gonna be a
fun draw
so rc8 androx e8s are out so you
basically
have two moves or capsaicin rook g8
does it matter which one do you do
keep in mind we wanna we want to
cut the knight sure let me call him up
and be like hey magnus do you know
how to win this why not i'll keep you
guys on the line rook stroke f8 is
actually the best one
because after check and now i'm still
pressuring your knight and you see
the knight is cut can't go to f7 can't
go to the f5 can go to e8
you can go to e4 you can go to c4 and
you can go to b7
if it goes to b7 we go to f7 and this is
winning right
careful not to take this because we
don't want to do a stillmate
not king b6 is winning because next move
we're gonna have checkmates
so
what about knight e4 how are we gonna
do with that knight e4
i told you guys i gave it a heads up to
get your popcorns and
coffee or whatever else you're gonna
need for this one this is this is rough
yes to rook f7 if the king goes to
a8 king b6 and next move
mutt um
if king goes to a6 can somebody tell me
how do we win this
exactly rookie four thank you aryan
denver c4
what if king goes to b8
what popcorns are not good for your
health
there was another thing that i like to
eat popcorns are basically a food group
for me
so right now king b6 doesn't really work
because the king can just run
so exactly matthew we actually have to
do this rook b7
if king c8 now rook e7 we're gonna take
we're gonna eat your knight or give you
checkmates
right knight f6 rookie six king a8
rook b4 move the knight if you go like
knight g5
off just keep chasing that and then i'll
just
have that king b6 so the whole idea is
something like
i'm gonna use the fact that your knight
is defenseless to
get your to have your king in the corner
to give you checkmates
i guess that's the summary of this
position um
but it's not that easy like it's knight
c3 then
something like your c4 and you really
have to try
and try but that's the thing you're
eventually going to get it
so yeah all right so let's go back
to knight c4 so if you're playing this
as black
you should already be thinking about
okay so that shows me i should not
keep i should not really fly so far away
with my knight
and i should keep my knight close to my
king right so
that's what the black is trying to do
right now knight c4
now why to move what do you think is the
best move
for whites
exactly we don't want the wild horse
uh i guess why you want to do rook five
button
sorry man
okay i guess this move might be too hard
for you guys
i'll give it another few seconds
nope i still don't see the right move in
the chat
um this is a move that if i didn't know
beforehand i probably wouldn't find
either
so it's actually rook d8
what right rook d8
um now let's start from the bad moves
what if knight goes to e3
so you see again you want to keep your
rook on the eighth rank so the king
can't do anything so you're forcing him
to keep
moving the knight into wars and wars and
worse positions
so between the eighth rank let's see why
rook d8 is the best one
if he makes a mistake and goes knight e3
you're just gonna give check
and depending we just saw what happens
in the previous position if you play
like king a8 i have king b6 if you play
king b8
um i have like rookie seven and
still um that's going to be quite
painful wait
yeah um if you
played something like
[Music]
so sorry my bad if you played king b8
first rook b7 if king there rookie seven
and if after check you went king a8
then i would still have rookie seven you
move the knight and i have king b6
okay sorry uh that was something i had
to clarify
if you go like check king b5 and if you
go
knight b7 now we are back in that
position
and your knight is actually about to
fall
uh pretty soon so remember the first
position
first position was this right we played
king b5 and knight b7
and we played drake f8 and your knight
went to d6
and your knight started to jump and now
we're talking about knight five
knight b7 so what do you think is wrong
with this
huh yeah um rook c7 i believe
because then you have you're attacking
the knight and you want to give
checkmate
so he can't really stop it stop it both
all right
so we looked at knight a5 what about
knight b2
we saw something like knight b2 in the
previous position two
so what do you want to do after knight
b2
pen city huh
you want to trap the knight yeah rook d4
awesome thank you
stefan
king a8 king b6 and you're going to be
checkmated pretty soon
and you see the beauty of it is that
this knight cannot go anywhere
right awesome well i mean i'll eat that
um
what about knight a3 do you think about
knight a3
okay c5 no i don't want king c5 i want
to
continuously have threats for your
knights casey that doesn't have a threat
for the knight
rook d4 does i want to do okay for and i
want to ask
for your knight's hand and knight c2
rookie 4 and finally this
king b6 and c because the knight is on
c2
i'm gonna give you cool checkmate
exactly be easy i think that is
that is one way to think about it yeah
so knight a3 doesn't work what about
knight b6
going back to basics
what do you think white can do after
knight b6
all right i see some interesting ideas
huh knight a3 was confusing yeah see all
of these lines are confusing so
um
enjoy the game and sleep honestly at
this point i got homework to do
but rook d4 is actually
exactly thank you muhammad rick d4 is
the best one
because after ah boy
because after rook d4
well you kind of cut the knight right
because of king can't go anywhere too
so um now black can only play
pretty much do knight c8 now king c7
threatening mate trading your knight
i'm just going to chill with that knight
and
now this is winning right
zugswang however keep in mind
that so far the only absolute drop
position that we saw
was this rook h7 kd8 so
this is what we don't want we don't want
the king to get to the eighth rank we
don't want the knight to be on d8
we do not want this so anything else
uh we kind of we're kind of doing fine
so we did this
rook f8 rook d8
and knight e5 check now where do you
want to put your king
you can go c7 you can go
b5 you can go c5 you can't go d6
so i see a lot of b5s but what about c5
what's wrong with c5 why don't you guys
like
c5
well everybody's saying b5 whoa
actually king c5 is the best one sorry
for misleading you
so for king c5 king b7 is like the most
feisty one for black which we will do
rook d5
but let's take a quick pause and look at
what if anything else besides king
king b7 so what if knight goes to
g6 then what knight is far far ahead
that's a one wild horse
how are we gonna win this
yep we don't want to draw after 15
minutes but yeah ideally we want to like
separate the king and the night as much
as possible and use the fact that the
knight is
lonely to attack it and give the king
checkmates or just check and pick up the
knights
so rook d4 is actually the best one we
saw a lot of this idea with dirk d4
so far in this puzzle right and the
thing is after rook
d2 i'm sorry after rook d4
um you're quote you're taking away so
many squares from blacks night
king b7 um chain d6
and actually in this position i doubt
you guys have any
have have a hard time winning this
because you're just gonna go after the
night basically
and you will eat the night
so what if it goes knight g4
any suggestions
king d4 king d4 is easier you're gonna
go hunt that knight to dear king
and um after king d4
f9 f6 rook f8 and that knight is already
meeting his creator because if knight d7
or knight h7 or cap7 if knight goes to
h5 that's also super duper corner
i'll give it maybe three more moves
before it goes into my belly
um so king b7
what about king b7
yeah knight kind of does like squares
you're correct so right now
the knight can't come to the e file so
we got to play rook cafe to take away
the f file as well
right logical and then you're just going
to attack this guy
you're going to go after it and you are
going to eat it
very deliciously all right so
one more line to look at knight f3
instead of king b7
so what about knight f3
yes that is hard to find move that
doesn't mean but it's also hard to find
a move that does win
so you got to do it accurate
um rook d5 oh exactly
good one um joseph
work d5 you're gonna cut that ninth on
the fifth rank
now if something like um
let's take a look at for example knight
h4
now we do rook g5 keep cutting that
knight
keep that knight cut
and you're just gonna come eat it with
your king and with the help of your rook
eventually that night will go bye-bye
um no the bishop is different so we'll
take a look at bishop as well
hopefully tonight
but
if even if something like knight d2
instead of going on h4 we're still going
to do the same things
take the square away from the knight
bring up your king to put it in the
corner
and eat the knight um
ah i wanted to show you this knight h2
as well
if knight h2 still rook f5 you cut the
key you cut the
knight same ideas if knight goes to h6
still rook f6 and we are gonna
simply eat the bring the knight closer
to the corner
um no these moves are not the only
winning moves but these are the most
accurate ones
because the plan is that you're going to
separate the knight from the king
put it in the corner eat it right so
these are like the best ways to do it
but these are not the only ways and we
mentioned this site as well
so i'm just basically right now showing
you different ways of trapping and
eating the night
so i feel like you guys have understood
the idea so i'm going to move on with
oh actually did i show you knight to e1
so many lines
yeah i didn't show you knight e1 but
this is also the same idea you give me
check
i'm going to come after your knight you
don't give me check you go to c2
i'll again put that rook on g3 like
right above it
um diagonally and i'll
peacefully bring my king to eat it all
right so you guys seen a lot of this
idea
i'm a little tired of this idea i feel
like i'm gonna have a dream about this
idea tonight or rather nightmare
so what about king b7
anybody has a move for me we're almost
done with it there's few more
different lines to look at different
ways to eat the night
i think there should be a song about
this
have i ever had an end game like this
no i had end games that pawns were
involved
it is a nightmare exactly with a k
um yeah roof d5 again that's the best
way to go you're going to keep pushing
the
knight so nike only can go to oops g6
and
g4 so if knight goes to g6 we're just
going to bring in the king the knight is
already getting close to the corner
and we are gonna we've seen something
similarly like this
we're just continuously gonna go put
that baby in a corner and eat it
soon right
okay so what about knight g4 can we
still apply the same logic of
eating the night i showed you what would
what would we do with knight's g6
so i'm hoping you guys will tell me what
to do with knight g4
it is really hard to calculate in the
real game i remember when i was actually
sitting behind the chess board and
trying to answer these
this took forever and i was just like
that's my puzzle of the day i'm not
looking at anything else
so actually you have to realize the king
kind of broke free a little bit
and the knight is super far away so you
gotta still try to have
somewhat of a cut for the king so king
d6 actually is the best one
and king d6 if something like a knight
f2
well actually if something like knight
f6 we just have rookie five and the
the knight is still pretty um cut
something like knight f2 we still do
rook d4
cutting the knight and
finally bringing our king
when is my finally eating this night
finally
all right it's a lot of night eating
honestly
um it sounds like knight e3 we can also
continue with rook b5
get the king in bring in the rook
and finally this and you see when the
king is in the corner we could actually
focus on mating the king
but the king but when the king starts to
get a little bit
closer uh from the at the
corner then we could actually go for the
knight
so i think that's one way to look at it
so king b6 seems to be
the longest try rook d2
rook d2 i'm not letting you run away
i'm still keeping this night minimized
i have had lunch i think yes
okay um so
after rook d2 uh
if knight f6 oh this is actually nice
this is kind of clear
check keep the knight
cut go after the knight
slowly keep the king cut
bring in the king keep the king cut
keep the knight cut you see how
beautiful it's being done
you cut the king then you cut the night
steam was like kind of like almost
simultaneously exactly
then you go after that cute little night
and you finally finally eat it
alright so this was a very long line
let's go back what if knight e3
i'm not going to eat a horse poor horse
the only horse i'll eat is this one
be easy i guess you've been watching me
for a while kind of
probably true
huh two day homework yeah
all right i think we're honestly we're
almost done with this we're just gonna
eat the night
or give checkmate i'm fine with either
so now
if knight goes to e3 we have rick p2
kick the king away
keep the king cut and you know if he
doesn't if he lets us we're gonna do a
checkmate
and then come back kick the knight
something like knight f5 rook d3
see you can't move with your king you
got to move your knight
i'm going to take that f5 square away
from your knight
uh there's something like knight c8 rook
f7 and that
knight is already going in my belly
uh if you went my g8 still king d6
and i got your knight in the corner i
feel like i need to sing a song about
knights in the corner
also kind of sounds shady but all right
so
knight g6 let's bring the king
let's bring more pieces i really gotta
eat that night
soon there we go finally next move rick
h6
and rick h2 and then knight goes to e1
and then the rook is on h2 so your
knight can't go anywhere
then king e3 rookie two bye bye night
all right i think this was the longest
puzzle
of my life let's move on i need to i
need a break from the knights
oh no why am i saving this okay
all right so this is a smaller one this
is a smaller version
so i'm going to leave you live this up
to you guys
but tell me what do you want to do
we just did a super gigantic way of
eating nights
so i expect you guys to be able to give
me some idea
i think we just feel like half an hour
on that
love story between the rook and the
night
the way that rook was chasing at night
that's the way i want to be
chased by my mcat books
i also am not the biggest fan of end
games
myself i prefer to mate a game like
i play a 15 minute game i'll mate you in
five moves voila
yeah oh queen and games are a
whole other headache that's some that's
that's also another thing that i plan to
do
not tonight though tonight
we are focusing on horses
yeah so does anybody have a move for me
i see some rook d7s
i see some rook f5s yeah exactly rookie
5 is the best one
you gotta keep that you kick that knight
remember
knight d2 now the knight might want to
go to e4
so we'll get four i'm taking three of
your vital squares four if you write
those squares away so you have knight b3
or knight b1 knight b1 oh that's going
to be the best day of my life
this king b4 and it's almost done
uh actually brook b4
no rook b4 why did i do king before
same thing with if knight b3 check now
we do king b4 sorry my bad
knight c1 now again remember
kings love to take away squares from the
knights
right
and finally we eat that night that's
stubborn night
all right so what if king a6
anybody want to tell me how to eat this
night now
yeah i need a break from nights honestly
after this
tonight's class
exactly starter of course obviously this
is a beginner class
right
exactly king b4 king c3
king b2 king c2
finally all right
no more night no more nights okay i can
deal with this night
so what have we got what do we want to
do in this one this is a good kind of
having a night ah this is so much fun
so white to move what are we going to do
to black
yep exactly ah my headache is gone
knight f6 is so pretty yep i mean he
tries like jerk a7 i'm just gonna
kind of just actually eat here for the
fun of it
but no i'm just gonna eat over there and
this is gonna be way too much fun all
right so now
this position white to move what to do
exactly if you're always looking at hard
stuff your brain is going to just
melt down so it's good to have a little
little baby breaks
so why to move how are we gonna survive
this
because he's attacking our rook and he
wants to give us checkmates so who
connect rooks
um so those of you who are saying rook
hitch five what if king takes f4
sorry sorry i thought you were saying
one second this position is
while wheeling it from white that is my
bad i don't know why i flipped the
position from the beginning
in this position here being h1
not a8 as i mistakenly assumed hoof
even those knights are still jumping in
my head
so now yes turkish five exactly
um after rookie five if you take
narrow k6 i'll pick this guy up right i
think this was very beautiful
yeah all right awesome
what about this one i mean this one is
the same idea too so i'm not gonna even
bother asking you
oh what about this one ah this is
no this is nice i want to be doing 26
000 puzzles of these
yep alright you guys got this
this is nice oh
not this all right so
why it's to move how do we win
we gotta do this rookie one i think rook
f4 android f7 also work
so if you were to play like qriket four
and just rook h4 this is like an easy
version to win
but uh obviously rook four he wouldn't
necessarily move his rook like he would
just keep the rook here so
keep in mind uh same with rook f7 king
e8
dan rook f4 then drew e4 thinking of
seven and then this is
another way of trying to win it like
same bridge
type of deal um well not
everything wins but yeah you're correct
a lot of the different ways to win
so rook e
1 also
if i'm not mistaken
this position was first published in
1497.
so it's like i'm not even going to do
the math just
sick so many years ago
14 19 7. holy
guacamole exactly lucina
yep i have trouble pronunciating it but
yes
all right so
um what about exactly thank you
523 years ago
so what about 31 what are we going to do
after that
probably king if with king f6 well
that's already a wrap right
what about king d6
now king d6 what do you think white's
gonna do
we got the rookie four i think hang f8
is also just gonna work
like a charm right this is easy busy win
what about king d7
if you do king f7 check check check
bunch of chicks so you gotta do ricky
for exactly your quest one king up
and you're gonna bridge it up
all right good
takes forever to do that so
now what about this position are we
still gonna win this as well
why to move
oh well thank you thank you for staying
[Music]
around
um roof d4 is actually the best not
drift d5 but yes
if you do king e6 i'm just going to get
my king out
i'm just going to do this lovely
if you played something like rook a2 now
i can do the king c7
bridge i'm gonna bridge and i'm gonna
bridge
and bridge all right great
this is a little bit longer but nothing
we can't get through
what about this position why it's to
move
yeah we're just trying to like place the
pawn in different spots and see how it
goes
basically
i think rookie 4 does work
yeah i think this is the one of the
easiest way to go about it
however rook a1 is something that they
tried
and like rookie one the problem is that
like if you try to go
that way it just makes it even a little
bit complicated
but because we have this possibility of
just running away
because um then if the rook is
protecting the eighth rank
we're gonna do that um
the only thing that i guess doesn't win
is the early king e7 just because
then your king is way too far ahead from
your pawn
far away from your pawn so what about
this one
white to move this one is about to clean
what can we do as white
king f4 push
now what is this going to be a win draw
what are you fighting for
yep king c7 should we play b7 or king b8
i think b7 is the
easiest way to get the draw
and do we know how to draw this i think
we all do right
just put your king on a um
just put your king on c8 uh best not to
do the king a8 because then you give
your opponents
the chance to bring king b3 right
we should we don't really want to do
that you know
we don't want to self-mate
so just be careful not to do that just
king c8 you're forcing
do you want to do queen so you're
forcing
some sort of check or some sort of um
stopping the queen and y'all know how to
draw this right just don't play king e8
okay so that is kind of all the time i
have for today i
i'm not gonna say that's all the
material i have for today because i told
you i got 20
26 000 puzzles just like this
all right so um thank you guys for
staying around with me and make sure to
tune in
for our other content for youtube and
twitch
and i will be on twitch teaching lessons
from five to seven cent lose time uh
on friday all right have a great rest of
your week
you